massive debate over the summer over the
attitude towards Israel and panting the
anti-semitism issue what's your take on
that my take on that is this that after
the Second Intifada the Israeli
embassies under the direction of the
Israeli Foreign Office were told start
labeling opponents to Israel in our
policies as anti-semitic all over the
globe
well in some cases they had more success
than others and in Britain that they had
had no success on this very little
because most of the English Jewish
organizations want politicized as that
but recently with Alban you see behind
this I mean in terms of actual
anti-semitism Atticus's in Britain it
has the lowest record of incidents
reported Idaho down of Yoram by the way
very low proportion so you have a tiny
group of Jewish organizations opposed by
other Jews organizations Jews for peace
Jews for labor who support koban and
have said that but the publicity and the
campaign that is created is based
largely largely not exclusively on
conservative Jews with the backing of
the right-wing inside the parliamentary
Labour Party this is what's going on
because there is a layer of people
within the parliamentary Labour Party
who would rather labor lost than Corbin
won and they think like that 60 or 70 of
his own MPs and they've been backing
this campaign as if suddenly
anti-semitism is read what's the reason
for that is that Obon has had a very
even-handed and justified position on
Palestine saying that what is happening
in Palestine is unacceptable which is
the position also I would say about a
50% of Jews in this country and an
increasing number of them in the United
States especially the young gender
generation
want to justify what is being done to
the Palestinians that's that maybe
tribute they're still a minority in this
country 260,000 Jews a small group and
they you know a lot of them do you feel
like I'm the way in which the issue is
talked about is insensitive or is
doesn't take account of the complexities
of the subject and the law to do do you
see that there has there has been a
strain of anti-semitism on the left
which is I won't really challenge that I
mean you know I have lived and worked on
the left of 1/5 last 50 years and the
one thing the left has always been very
strong on is anti-semitism anti racism a
lot I mean look at Corbin at the age of
14 in a Shropshire village water is the
first organisation he joins Shropshire
against racism what does he do as a
young teenager go on his bike to all the
local truck show villages distributing
leaflets against racism I've spent a lot
of time with him on platforms over the
last years denouncing racism and
anti-semitism now this doesn't mean that
anti-semitism doesn't exist and people
say stupid things but I in my opinion
there are two forms of anti-semitism one
is a philosophical anti-semitism based
on centuries of Christian theology which
erupted in that brutal way in Germany
where Luther himself was deeply
anti-semitic as a Protestant reformer
deeply anti-semitic so there's that
strain in German Christian culture
within Islam there is no philosophical
basis for this at all and the bulk of
their existence
as rulers the Muslims and Jews work
together till the late 1940s a lot of
this casual unacceptable anti-semitism
is the result of what Israel does to the
Palestinians it is linked
to that and denying it to my mind is
just foolish it implies that somehow
people have suddenly gone mad I mean
it's unacceptable but that is the reason
it's there every time Palestinians are
killed and no politician or very few
open their mouths America supports it so
you know this is the result I remember
saying this at the Jewish Book Festival
about six years ago I said the end it's
an audience largely of Jewish people
here in London in enhanced it not too
far away from here and I said that if
this carries on you will have young
people growing up in this country in
others and who if you say to them if
they attack or criticize Israel you're
anti-semitic they will have no memory of
anything they'll say okay if you want to
call us that call us that we don't care
that's exactly what has happened but
even that has happened to a very sort of
small extent it's been exaggerated way
beyond and you know Corbin was told if
you sign up for the IHRA which lots of
Jewish lawyers people of Jewish origin
was saying is a scandal
you'll be fine well they've signed up to
it have the attacks stopped no they
carry on once you gave into this stuff
it's never-ending